[Music]
Scotland
your reality
everything you're holding on to
[Music]
yeah if you leave
at man
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and yesterday we got the official
trailer for Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. it was pretty epic but we also got a
new little teaser for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania now it wasn't a trailer
with two minutes of new footage because
it's mostly a legacy trailer however
there is some new footage in it towards
the end and there are a couple of
surprising things here to break down
specifically with what king says and how
he says it because there's actually a
difference between this trailer and the
trailer that we got before now Kang
seems to think that he knows how
ant-man's future ends he knows Scott
Lang's entire path because Kang is the
master of time travel he can go forward
in time backwards in time anywhere in
time that he wants he can even jump
through different realities different
universes however I believe that Ant-Man
actually going inside of the quantum
realm changes everything and that by
doing so and confronting King the
Conqueror in the quantum realm that
actually changes Ant-Man future entirely
and Kang doesn't actually know what's
going to happen you see the first thing
that you need to know about Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania is that we are not
only going to see one Kang the Conqueror
in fact in the trailer we've already
seen two different variants of King
maybe even three this complicates the
story of Ant-Man just a little bit
because there is going to be one very
clear and very present bad guy it'll be
pretty clear who the villain of the
movie is a variant of Kang however it's
not the main variant that we're going to
be coming in contact with as we follow
Scotland on this journey the main King
that we're going to be seeing is the
main King that we see in this trailer
that is speaking to Ant-Man at the end
this is a king the Conqueror that is
stuck inside of the quantum realm not
the ruler of the quantum realm or the
quantum City that we believe is
chronopolis the home base of Kang the
Conqueror in the comics the main Kane
that we see in this trailer is not in
charge of chronopolis that is a
different King but the one that Scott
Lang is interacting with the one that
gives him an ultimatum and says so
what's it going to be Ant-Man this is a
different King that Scott is actually
going to work with so although during
the film we're going to basically know
that this version of King the Conqueror
this variant isn't exactly a good guy
he's not the big bad of the quantum
realm that's a different version of King
so the situation for Ant-Man kind of
becomes an enemy of my enemy is my
friend type of deal however of course as
we know as we've been warned by he who
remains most variants of Kang the
Conqueror are Super Evil
if you think I'm
evil well this way
until you meet all right
and the King that wants ant-man's help
to overthrow the other king the
Conqueror the leader of chronopolis
right now only wants to become the big
bad himself and unfortunately he's going
to back Ant-Man into a corner in order
to get him to help him however Kang
doesn't know everything that he thinks
he knows let me explain what I mean here
in the first trailer that we got for
Ant-Man and the WASP of quantumania we
hear King the conqueror's voice talking
to Scott Lang and he says this place it
isn't what you think I can get you home
and give you more time if you help me so
what's it gonna be Ant-Man now in this
new trailer and the new footage that we
got King the Conqueror tells something
different to Scott this King the
Conqueror actually calls him by name he
starts off by saying Scott Lang then he
says your reality everything you're
holding on to I Know How It Ends you're
out of your league Ant-Man and what's
really interesting here is that I think
this particular line from King the
Conqueror right here is a mistake on his
part or a lie you see we already know
that the big bad of this movie came the
Conqueror a variant of Kang has set up
shop inside of the quantum realm and
he's established chronopolis we can see
in both trailers that he has a huge Army
he has a giant City in which he is
ruling over also not to mention the
quantum realm gives off a lot of quantum
energy so I'm sure he's found a way to
harness that energy as well so he's
extremely powerful however there is a
specific reason why Kang the Conqueror
chose the quantum realm to establish his
base and that is because the quantum
realm exists outside of space and time
and this is a huge factor that you
cannot forget and this actually explains
why Kang the Conqueror is inside of the
quantum realm because if you think back
to what he who remains said Kang's
greatest adversary is himself is the
other variant of himself and keep in
mind came the Conqueror in multiple
variants of King are Master Time
Travelers so if you are anywhere in the
real Universe in reality a king the
Conqueror could show up out of nowhere
and kill you however if you are inside
of the quantum realm I don't believe
that can happen because it does exist
outside of time and space so essentially
King the Conqueror chose the quantum
realm to hide from the other versions of
King however another variant the one
that we hear talking in this trailer has
found this main King the Conqueror
variant inside of the quantum realm and
his whole purpose in this movie is going
to overthrow this came to conquer and
become the leader of chronopolis however
he needs ant-man's help to do it he
needs him to steal something most likely
the power source that can power Kang the
conqueror's time chair this is why this
variant of King needs Ant-Man because he
is most likely stuck inside of the
quantum realm you see the quantum realm
is great for a base you are protected
but you also can't really conquer
anything else if you stay stuck inside
of it however as we learned in Avengers
end game there are a ton of portals that
you can use inside of the quantum realm
to time travel this is where Kang's time
chair comes in he can use it to go in
and out of the quantum realm at any
point in time he can use it to go
conquer however if you're like the other
variant you can't really do much if you
can't escape the quantum realm and
that's where Scott comes in however I
think my Ant-Man simply entering the
quantum realm he kind of changes his
future you see this Kang tells Scott
that he knows how his reality ends
however I think that's a lie or Kang
perhaps made a mistake yes Kang can
control time he is the master of time
travel he can go forward backwards
sideways whatever you name it however he
can't see inside of the quantum realm
because that exists outside of space and
time so simply by Scott entering the
quantum realm this changes everything
because it is a part that Kang and his
variants cannot see so either Kang
doesn't realize this or he simply lying
to Ant-Man to scare him and get him to
work for him so the quantum realm is a
big Advantage but also can be a pretty
big disadvantage to King the Conqueror
and his variants as well you see Kang
may think that he could see all of
Scott's future but anytime that Scott
enters the quantum realm Ken can't see
it unless he is physically there to
monitor and watch Ant-Man this is why
the quantum realm is so crucial it's
actually crucial to the villain and the
hero whoever the variant of Kang at any
point in time is in charge of the
quantum realm has the ultimate advantage
over the other kangs this can can
essentially hide in the quantum realm
from all of the other ones then pop out
kill one and go back into hiding this
Kang variant can do this essentially
until all of the other ones are dead
this is kind of what he who remains did
he secluded his timeline from all of the
other timelines out there then he
protected it to make sure no other kangs
could pop up that was the true point of
him inventing the TVA to keep other Kang
variants away to avoid that multiversal
war that's essentially what the quantum
realm can do for any variant of King at
any point in time unless however they
managed to go inside of the quantum
realm and I'm assuming since there are
infinite amounts of King variants some
of them have figured out how to do that
fortunately for whoever is in charge of
the quantum realm at the time they will
have a massive Army to defend but
essentially I think that's what we're
going to see happen in quantumania a
Kang is going to be in charge of
chronopolis and other Kang variants are
going to try to take over unfortunately
for Scott Lang's case he's going to be
roped into helping Kang Dethrone another
one and the reason is because he's going
to take his daughter Cassie Lang hostage
threatening to kill her if she doesn't
help also threatening his actual reality
which I do believe is kind of a bluff
because I think Ant-Man is not going to
know that Kang is stuck inside of the
quantum realm I think Kang will probably
lie to him stating that he's in the
quantum realm for a purpose trying to
take over this other King's Empire
because he is Super Evil and he isn't as
evil giving Scott some crap about how
the person in charge right now is a
super evil person that wants to take
over the entire Multiverse but this King
simply wants to rule over the quantum
realm I'm assuming we'll see something
like that and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania but let me know what you
think about this and my theory in the
comments down below do you think this
was a mistake by King or do you simply
think he is lying leave your comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf